While we're still waiting on official confirmation
of the rumor that Charlie Cox's Matt Murdock,
a.k.a. Daredevil, will appear in the upcoming
third Spider-Man movie as Peter Parker's lawyer,
it seems the fate of one of Cox's co-stars
on Netflix's The Defenders might be starting
to take shape.
According to We Got This Covered, Marvel brass
may be looking to slot the one and only Luke
Cage into the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
the near future, with the Hero of Harlem reportedly
set to feature as a prominent supporting player
moving forward.
The rumor is hardly substantiated, as the
outlet cites an unnamed Marvel insider as
the source the same who leaked Cox's possible
MCU return in Spider-Man 3.
It appears that Marvel Entertainment Chief
Creative Officer Kevin Feige isn't looking
to simply forget all of the Netflix small-screen
MCU ventures.
He's reportedly looking to integrate not only
Daredevil and Luke Cage into the MCU, but
also Jessica Jones and the Punisher, with
Krysten Ritter and Jon Bernthal both possibly
reprising their roles.
Most surprisingly, the rumor claims that Marvel
isn't interested in bringing actor Mike Colter
back as Cage.
The studio is reportedly looking to recast
the role, a fate apparently also shared by
Iron Fist's Finn Jones.
If these rumors turn out to be true, let's
hope that Marvel finds an actor who can balance
physicality and emotion as well as Colter
did over his time in the Netflix world of
the MCU.
"Yo, I'm doing the best I can, OK?"
Marvel is bringing some of its big-screen
heroes to the small screen via Disney+, so
it's not unreasonable to believe that perhaps
the studio wants to blend the heroes of those
Netflix series into the ever-expanding cinematic
universe.
According to Variety, certain legalities between
Marvel and Netflix may prevent any of the
characters who appeared on those streaming
series from joining in the MCU until at least
two years after their respective series ended.
Daredevil aired its final run of episodes
in October 2018, so it'll be at least another
year before we see the man without fear in
the MCU.
For the Punisher and Jessica Jones, the wait
would be a little longer, as final episodes
of their series aired in January and June
of 2019, respectively.
As for a possible timeline on a Luke Cage
return, he was last seen getting cozy in Harlem's
Paradise in June 2018, so it's possible he
could be punching his way back into the MCU
sooner than any of the other Defenders.
"I don't plan on hibernating.
I was innocent before and I'm innocent now.
I got work to do."
Part of the reason these particular characters
made their debuts in small-screen ventures
is because Marvel probably had them marked
as worthy heroes that likely wouldn't have
drawn huge audiences to theaters in a standalone
movie.
Daredevil's only solo movie venture is not
well-regarded, let's say.
Luke Cage in particular seemed to benefit
from the episodic approach, as well as from
teaming up with other supers in Netflix's
Marvel canon, memorably pairing with both
Jessica Jones and Iron Fist prior to and after
the Defenders' run.
Cage has been one of Marvel Comics' most team-up-friendly
heroes over the years, so if Feige and the
current Marvel crew are eyeing him as a major
supporting player in whatever MCU fun they
might be planning, there's a chance that the
Hero of Harlem could turn up alongside some
more established supers right out of the gate.
Cage's status as an Avenger has been well-established
in the comics, and if the MCU truly is looking
to build its next Avengers big-screen run,
Cage could find himself in the mix when the
next crossover occurs.
We could also see Marvel go the Heroes for
Hire route and deposit Cage in the company
of his Defenders pals Iron Fist and Jessica
Jones.
It's also been rumored that Marvel is looking
to bring an alternate super-group into the
MCU in the near future: The Thunderbolts.
And yes, Luke Cage can frequently be seen
fighting alongside that crew, too.
So Cage's possible return to the MCU could
take on many different looks.
Could it happen?
Of course.
Might it be an out-and-out farce?
Sure.
Marvel rumors are a dime a dozen.
But there's potentially a lot to look forward
to if he does find his way back.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.